in America the video showing Tyree
Nichols fatal beating remains hard to
watch and to process
it prompted demonstrations across the
country this was Times Square in New
York where several arrests were made
this was the scene on the west coast but
crowds took to the streets of Los
Angeles following the video's release
first the city where Tyree Nichols lived
and died demonstrations extended into
the weekend we want the city to be a
safe place for our children
because as a mother and as a nurse I'm
worn the loss of um a kind soul I'm a
mother of five black sons one deceased
and it could have been very well on my
side whatever the causes are we need to
try to resolve them and not have this
because constantly be the end result
this was the footage released from a
CCTV camera at the spot where Tyree
Nichols was beaten by officers
where he spoke his last words calling
out for his mum who lived nearby
the police officers who inflicted fatal
injuries on this street corner now face
charges of second-degree murder the
charges represent a swift response to
the brutal tragic events that took place
here caught on camera that street camera
as well as the body cams worn by the
officers who killed Tyree Nichols but
there remain outstanding questions
around police culture a culture that
puts officers on the street behaving
like they did confident that they could
former president Barack Obama and his
wife Michelle tweeted that this was just
the latest painful reminder of how far
America still has to go in fixing how we
police our streets
the five police officers involved all
black men have been released on bail
pending further proceedings there is
certainly an element of racist policing
in the type of unit that was employed
here they unfairly Target minority
communities
because that's where they believe that
the crime needs to be stopped so what
they're doing is they're conducting
pretextual type of stops and usually the
targets are brown and blacks and in this
particular instance Tyree was caught up
as an innocent victim of this
pre-textualism that they were conducting
and look at what happened a traffic stop
which turned deadly
at various points in the video we see
officers affected by their own pepper
spray
they're now talking about it in the wake
of the beating
the lawyer for one Desmond Mills JR says
there are questions around what he knew
and was able to see subsequently
it is the makings of a defense amidst
the seemingly indefensible
James Matthews Sky News in Memphis